[MUSIC PLAYING]
AMIR HERMELIN: Hello, everyone,
and welcome to our session,
Seeing Inside Your Service.
My name is Amir
Hermelin, and I'm
a product manager for Google.
And with me is Asaph Zemach, an
engineering manager for Google.
And we're here to talk
about the exciting things
we're doing and planning
for monitoring and logging.
Before I start, I'd like to
thank you all for attending,
for coming to our conference,
showing your support,
being loyal Google Cloud
users, so we really
rely on your support
and feedback.
So thank you.
Before we start, a show
of hands-- how many of you
actively monitor your services?
Please raise your hands.
OK, great.
You're in the right place.
Keep them up.
How many of you like it
when you're firefighting,
and you're sifting
through the information,
trying to drill down and find
the relevant information?
OK, that's good.
That's good.
And how many of you love it
when you're woken up at 3:00 AM
to do that?
OK, you two-- you're
our lucky winners.
Now, the rest of you--
oh, where's my clicker?
Here's what we're going
to be talking about.
So quick look at
the agenda-- we'll
start with what we've learned
over the years and our plans
and vision for logging
and monitoring.
Then, we'll talk a little
about our new Logs Viewer.
You may have seen it at
this morning's keynote,
and our logs ingestion pipeline.
We'll then go over
our new time series
API, which is the first of many
upcoming APIs in this area.
And we'll conclude with a quick
demo-- putting it all together.
So monitoring at Google--
as you're probably aware,
at Google, we run
many, many services.
And we've been doing so over
the years-- small services,
large services, from
really experimental
alpha-type services run by two,
three person teams, all the way
up to Google Search
and tens of thousands
of queries per
second services that
are managed by distributed
teams all over the globe.
And internally, we've
built very, very
capable and sophisticated
monitoring systems
for keeping these services up.
And over the years, we've
learned many lessons.
Some were harder to
learn than others.
But we think most of the things
we've learned apply equally
to large and small services,
no matter what you're running.
So some of the things that
we've learned over the years--
first of all, what you want
to do with your service
is you want to catch
problems early,
before these problems are
visible to your users.
Because when your
service is down,
or when your users have a hard
time accessing your service,
that means downtime.
You might lose revenue,
you might lose mind share,
you might lose users, and it
might be all over Twitter-land.
So you don't want to
get to that point.
You want to catch
problems early.
You want to be extra careful.
And so you go on.
You add alerts.
You add dashboards.
You have logs and all
sorts of indicators
to make you aware of
problems before they occur.
But that introduces
another thing.
That introduces noise.
That introduces a lot of
information-- whoops-- a lot
of information that
really desensitizes you
from the real issues that occur,
the real things that you should
focus on.
And so what we've
learned is that you
should focus on an
alert only on symptoms--
so focus on how will
things affect your users.
Will these things
affect the users?
Is this a real problem?
When will my users start sensing
it, and if you're firefighting,
where should I start?
I should start with
the things that
matter to my users, that
are visible to my users.
So that's what we've
learned over the years.
But of course, what we've
learned and what we've done
is not enough.
We went out and asked
you and other Cloud users
what they would like get from
their monitoring systems.
And so here's what
we're hearing from you.
Lots of you are telling
us that you've had alerts,
but you had too many of them.
They were noisy,
and you ended up
ignoring them-- maybe
partially, maybe in full.
How many of you
can relate to that?
OK, good-- well, it's not good.
But yeah, I see some
people in the audience
who know what I'm talking about.
A relevant thing--
maybe you've heard
or you remember in the past few
months, some credit card fraud
occurrences that happened
at large online retailers.
Now, in most-- probably
in all these cases,
from what I understand--
the problem was
not that they didn't
have indicators.
They actually had many logs.
They had many alerts.
They had many indicators.
They might have had
too many that they've
ignored some of them, that
they had a hard time sifting
through the rest of
them, and by the time
they found out
about the problem,
lots of credit card
information was stolen.
It became public,
a huge problem,
and these things sometimes
takes years to mend.
So that's being too noisy.
Now, too many of
you have told us
that our existing Log
Viewer for App Engine
is just not enough to
find the relevant logs.
You have many logs.
You have a lot of log volume,
and you'd like something better
to help you sift
through them and get
to the relevant information.
How many of you think that?
OK, good.
OK, you're in the
right place then.
I am too.
So most of you are
telling us that you
know you need a better
monitoring solution.
You know you need
better monitoring
and alerts for things that
are running in production,
but you just don't have
the time to spend on it.
You want to ship new features,
and you don't have the time
to become experts at monitoring.
And it's not just
learning the system,
but learning how to monitor.
And then absolutely no one--
except these two gentlemen
over there-- tell us that they
love to be woken up at 3 AM--
definitely if it's for
the wrong reasons, right?
Sometimes there are
the right reasons,
but if it's something that is
not urgent or could have been
handled automatically,
nobody likes that.
And unless you're a
parent to a toddler,
you don't really need to
wake up at those times.
So what you're telling us that
our monitoring solution needs
to need to be-- it needs to
be actionable, so everything
results in an action.
So alerts or dashboards are the
things that remove the noise
and help you focus
on the right things.
It needs to be scalable.
So even small teams can
manage huge services.
It needs to be easy to use,
so a great out-of-the-box
experience, and easy to iterate
upon until you get to the right
setup, the right
dashboards, alerts,
and logs that you're surfacing.
And it needs to be smart.
So if it does wake
you up at 3:00 AM,
you know you need to get out
of bed, and in your pajamas,
either grab your laptop or
get to work and fix something.
So where are we
going with all this?
So we took what we've learned
and our existing systems
and what you've been
telling us, and here's
what we want to do with
our monitoring systems.
Dashboards, alerts,
and logs-- we
want to surface only the
relevant information, right?
So you can understand
better what's happening
and how is it
affecting your users.
We want to minimize
false-positives,
so you can react faster
and not ignore real issues
before they occur or
during firefighting.
And we want to help you
automatically detect
issues and find relevant events
and relevant information that
helps you running your services
and production so that even
small teams can scale up
and monitor and manage
huge services.
So we want to help you be
insightful and react fast.
And I want to remind
you of something
that Bobby said this
morning-- the CTO of Snapchat.
He mentioned that they have a
relatively small team running
a huge service, right?
They have tens of
millions-- or probably
hundreds-- millions of users and
many, many queries per second.
And he said that most
of the time they spend
is on rolling out and iterating
on new features and very
little time on
managing the platform.
And that's what we
want to help you do.
We want to help you scale
monitoring so that we manage
your monitoring for
you, and you can
focus on getting
features out the door.
OK?
And with that, I'll
hand it over to Asaph.
ASAPH ZEMACH: OK.
Am I on?
OK, so the first thing I
want to introduce today
is our new Logs
Viewer and pipeline.
So here, we show the schematic
of the new logs pipeline
that we're introducing today.
This pipeline is today
hooked up to App Engine,
and we'll be hooking it
up to our other services
over the coming weeks.
And what the nice thing
about this pipeline is it's
a transport mechanism for logs
going from one Google service
to a number of Google endpoints.
The first of these endpoints
is the new Logs Viewer.
You've seen it demoed today
in Brad's keynote address.
And additional endpoints
that we're introducing today
are Google Cloud Storage.
So if, for example, you
have your App Engine logs,
and you want to do some
kind of batch processing
on top of that, you
want to run maybe
Hadoop on top of
that, you can enable,
you can opt in to this option
of having your logs show up
in Google Cloud Storage.
And what it'll do-- it will take
these logs, we'll buffer them,
and we'll produce hourly files
inside Google Cloud Storage,
and those are good
for batch processing.
Additional options for you
is to opt into BigQuery.
So for example, you can have
your logs-- your request logs,
as they're coming
out of App Engine,
flow through the
new logs pipeline
into BigQuery through
the new streaming
API that was announced today,
and have those available
for doing SQL queries
on top of them
for business intelligence
applications.
So that's the new logs pipeline.
And the Logs Viewer
is available today.
The Cloud Storage
and BigQuery options
are available to
Trusted Testers,
and Amir will give information
at the end of this presentation
of how to contact us and get to
be part of that Trusted Tester.
So this is the new Logs Viewer.
This is just a screenshot.
I will not be doing a demo of
it since Brad's has already
done it-- has gone
over all the features.
I do want to just go over
some of the improvements
we're introducing.
So the first of these
is infinite scroll.
It makes it a lot easier for
you to move around in a log,
to find a log you're
interested in,
to scroll up, to scroll down.
It works really well with
a mouse wheel, for example.
There's no more of the page
backwards, page forwards.
We think it's going to
be a lot more convenient.
The second thing is
automatic searches.
So this is probably the
number one feature request
we've had from the
old Logs Viewer.
I don't know if
anybody has ever run
into this-- when you do a
search, and nothing comes out,
and you have to page
forward to find it.
So raise your hand if you've
ever encountered this behavior?
Yeah, I thought so.
So this problem's now fixed.
Now, the new Logs Viewer
doesn't exhibit this behavior,
so I think that will make
a lot of people happier.
If we're already
talking about searches,
we've introduced an
improvement in searches
so now you can do a
search both on labels
and regular expressions
from the same search box.
So that's a lot
more convenient--
and have suggestions
as you type,
so if you're trying
to find, for example,
something where the results
code is 500 and also contains
the word "success," as you
start typing results code,
we'll help you
fill in that label.
So it makes the Logs
Viewer a lot easier to use.
So switching over from
talking over the Logs Viewer,
I want to introduce
one of our new APIs--
so the first of the monitoring
APIs we're making available,
and there'll be
many more coming.
So what is the monitoring API
that we're introducing today?
So we have a monitoring
system built inside Google
that what it does
is it periodically
samples important
system counters.
So right now, it's connected
through App Engine and Compute
Engine.
And we collect--
as these systems
are running, as they're
running your applications,
our monitoring system samples
various counters-- for example,
how many requests you've made,
what the latency of the request
was, how much CPU you're using.
And we're collecting all those.
We're passing those through a
pipeline of monitoring data,
and we're storing it
in a monitoring store.
And now today, we're
introducing an API which
allows you to access that
monitoring information
and get metrics-- a
time series of data--
so for example, the history
of all the result codes
you have in your App
Engine application,
or the history of your CPU
utilization in GC over time.
So one place where this time
series information is used
is you've seen all the nice
graphs in the Cloud Console.
Well, those are based off of
that time series information,
and that's one common
usage for that.
So this is a list of the metrics
we're making available today.
You see, we have a list
of App Engine metrics.
We have a list of
Compute Engine metrics,
and we can go into
them in more detail,
and we'll be introducing
much more later.
So what does a
request look like?
I'll go into this
in some detail.
So it's a standard REST request.
The first part of it is the URL.
Google APIs Cloud Monitoring
is where this API lives.
Then comes the version number.
So this is version v2
beta 1, so it's still
a fairly early
version of this API.
Then you tell us which
project you're interested in.
Then you tell us
what you want to get.
In this case, you're trying
to get a time series.
Then you're telling
us which service
you want to get the
time series for.
In this case, it's Compute.
There's an analogous
service for App Engine.
And similarly,
there's [INAUDIBLE]
instance information.
You're telling us which
metric you want to get.
In this case, you're telling
us you want the usage time.
And the response you get
for this is-- essentially,
it's a JSON object.
It tells you what
information you're getting.
There's some metadata.
For example, it tells you
what your project information,
the metric name, some
label information,
then followed by series
of points-- essentially,
a start, an end
time, and a value.
So it's a very classic
time-series information,
very simple to use.
And with that, I will
want to go to a demo.
So what are we going to see?
So earlier in the presentation
that Brad did here,
he showed the CloudMemeBackEnd.
So we had an application where
someone was using an Android
application to talk
to something running
in the front-end in App Engine.
And that was talking
to a back-end running
in Compute Engine.
And there was a MongoDB
element in there.
So all these things
were running,
and as they were
running, we were
in the background
collecting metrics for them
and putting them in the
Google Cloud metric store.
And now, we'll see how
we can access that.
So can we switch to the demo?
Excellent.
OK, so first, I will
go to my directory
to see I'm in the right place.
And now, I'm going to
log in using OAuth.
So the monitoring data
that we have is protected.
It's your monitoring data.
So it's not available using
standard cURL commands.
They have to be
OAuth-enabled cURL commands,
so your monitoring data can
only be accessed by you and not
by anybody else.
So here we used the
OAuth cURL command
that's available off
of code.google.com.
I log in.
It asks me to
allow access to it.
I allow the access.
And now, we create--
gives me an OAuth token.
The OAuth token is
stored on my machine.
It's good for about
an hour, and now, I
can issue an OAuth cURL command
to get my monitoring data.
So this is the Java
OAuth cURL command.
As you can see, it's
a fetch command,
so we're doing the OAuth fetch.
And we're getting the Google
APIs, as I showed earlier.
Memedroidbackend is the name
of the project on the computer,
in Google Cloud console.
And then we get
the exact instance.
And there it is.
It's all working.
You can see it tells us what we
got-- the kind of information,
some metadata, and
again, points, points,
points all the way down--
just time series information,
exactly as you would expect.
AMIR HERMELIN: Thank you.
Thank you, Asaph.
Let's give a hand for
Asaph and his team.
ASAPH ZEMACH: Thank you.
AMIR HERMELIN: His team
has been working hard
to get you these features
and the upcoming features.
Some of the things
that we're working on
is extending the APIs, bringing
you dashboards and alerts,
and working on other
logs functionality
to make the monitoring and
logging experience much better,
easily managed, and take
your time off of that
and so you can focus
on shipping features.
So a little bit
about-- again, what
we've covered today, right?
We spoke about our vision,
the things that we've learned.
We want to bring our systems,
our power, our scale,
our monitoring systems to you,
but in a simple and intuitive
way, so you can get
started quickly.
We showed you our new Logs
Viewer and our logs ingestion
pipeline-- which is, by
the way, in Trusted Tester,
and I'll tell you how can take
part in that in a little bit.
And we went through our time
series API-- which is, again,
is the first of upcoming APIs--
to give you programmatic access
to your data, to help you build
on top of what we're offering.
So you can extend
what we're offering
and do other things that we
might not have available today.
And we took you through a demo.
And I'll remind you that
what didn't work is plot,
which is not our stuff, but
the rest of it, I assure you,
is working well, and it
is in Trusted Tester --
our monitoring API.
So we thank you.
And one important
thing is we really,
really appreciate your comments,
suggestions, and feedback.
If you have something
you want to tell us,
or if you want to be part
of our Trusted Tester--
these are several Trusted Tester
programs-- the email is here.
I don't know if you can see it.
It's
monitoring-and-logs-feedback@google.com,
with dashes.
So
monitoring-and-logs-feedback@google.com,
with dashes.
And also, we'll be
here after we're
done to answer any questions.
Do we have time
for a little Q&A?
Yeah.
OK, so any questions?
And please, speak up.
MALE SPEAKER: No, we have a mic.
AMIR HERMELIN: Oh, OK.
We have a mic.
Awesome.
AUDIENCE: Was one of
the items that you
were able to monitor the
rights to the data store?
AMIR HERMELIN: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Were you able to
monitor the rights to the data
store?
ASAPH ZEMACH: Yes, so there's
a long list of metrics
that we showed available.
There is rights from
GC, rights to the disk,
and there's rights
to networking.
So there's both networking and
disk access metrics for GC--
well, for the Compute Engine.
For the App Engine,
I think it's mostly
around the-- we have-- can you
bring up the list of slides?
AMIR HERMELIN: Yeah.
ASAPH ZEMACH: So instead of me
trying to remember it by heart,
we can just bring it up.
We can just bring it up.
AMIR HERMELIN: By the way,
we're adding to this list.
ASAPH ZEMACH: OK, yes.
So we have responses.
We have quota denials,
usage, page speed,
received and sent
bytes over the network.
So that's what we
have available today.
So that's the list of stuff
we have available now.
And note, part of the reason
why we're doing Trusted Tester
is exactly to get
feedback to say, well,
you know, it really
would be useful for me
to get data store bytes--
so we can add that.
AMIR HERMELIN: Any
other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So you showed the
metrics from the App Engine
and Compute Engine going
into your metrics store.
Will you be able to
send external metrics
to the metric store
from an external source?
AMIR HERMELIN: So by external
source, you mean your own apps?
Or do you mean--
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
outside of Google.
AMIR HERMELIN: Yes, so we
will have a metric ingestion
API for your
user-defined metrics.
That is future, so I don't
want to talk about it too much.
But it will integrate with
the rest of the system
to be first-class citizens.
So all the wonderful things
that we're working on
for our metrics will also be
available for your metrics.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any similar plans
around Google Cloud Storage?
AMIR HERMELIN: So
the question was,
do we have any similar plans
around Google Cloud Storage,
and the answer is yes.
And there was a thumbs up.
Next question?
Ah, OK.
I think we're also
running out of time
and-- oh, one last question.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Can you show
again the email address,
because I was trying to--
AMIR HERMELIN: Yes, yes, yes.
Of course, of course, of course.
Monitoring-and-logs-feedback@google.com,
with dashes.
Or amirh@google.com if
you can't remember that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMIR HERMELIN: What's that?
AUDIENCE: I get an error
when I send an email to that.
ASAPH ZEMACH: He says
he gets an error when
he sends an email to that.
AMIR HERMELIN: Oh,OK.
Hmm-- give us--
AUDIENCE: Oh,
sorry. [INAUDIBLE].
AMIR HERMELIN: Oh, it works?
OK.
Enough things not working
for this session, right?
All right, thank you, everybody.
And please let us
know what you think.
We'd love to hear your feedback.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]